in the land of middle-earth ring race
usually strike fear into local residents
with the whole shrieking death thing but
in this clip we meet el tauriel who's
powerful enough to hunt them along with
killing a good chunk of orc recruits
that Talia may have wanted for himself
to see whether they work out their
differences give us the old thumbs up
and consider subscribing to our Channel
let's get to it clean wounds and they
never unsealed their weapons this looks
like yo tarios work she is
indiscriminate by the look of it some of
these would have made good followers we
must find her before she eliminates all
our potential recruits though if she did
we'd have little need of an army
[Music]
if you were looking for ring wraiths
you're too late but before I engaged him
he was speaking to an orc who was
different than the others there are
worms nearby perhaps they can tell us
what is going on if we take them alive
you don't decide whom I let live ring
maker you'd both do well to remember
that the nazgûl have dealings with
special orcs what are they
fight ends
what is the purpose of the chosen match
secure idea is something to do in the
sea in stone
that's all
so firm I like to rinse your shadow he
ever came back
what have the idea revealed only the
streakers know that the chosen kill
anyone else against love the chosen
where do they come from
the circus-like from is some kind of
Rachel all very sacred fire nowhere
more orcs are coming I'll deal with them
so long as the witch-king has the
volunteer any towers the chosen hold
will be his eyes then we must believe
the ritual to create the chosen where is
it before no one knows when a captain
selected the Shriekers in the world to
tell him where to go
we must hello Thalia what we load must
need not concern her we have our mission
and she has hers her mission is the
destruction of the enemy that tracks us
the more information we share the better
[Music]
we are messengers forthcoming the
witch-king is using the hydeia to track
the ring they extend the Palantir range
aux called the chosen garden and the
enemy may hold the Palantir but the idea
themselves are vulnerable we know a
design and how we dismantle it
you